first on cbs this morning a
congressional investigation raises
serious concerns about the safety of
some popular children's car booster
seats the probe began
after our cbs news and propublica
reports back in february
we showed you how some booster seats got
a passing grade
despite disturbing video of crass test
crash test dummies
being tossed violently around during
safety testing
well this morning we have new crash test
videos uncovered in the congressional
investigation
and our chris van cleave is going to
join us he's been following us for
months
to show us this is an industry-wide
problem chris good morning to you and
you've got some seats there with you i
see
good morning you know these booster
seats say things like side impact
tested and we're going to show you those
tests but it's important to know
the companies decide what qualifies as
passing now
booster seats raise a child up so the
adult seat belt in the back seat falls
in the right place all of these meet or
exceed federal standards
but this one says it's for kids 40 and
up here 30 pounds and up and that 10
pound difference that's where the
concern comes in because experts say for
kids weighing
less than 40 pounds a booster seat may
not offer
adequate protection in a crash
the videos are hard to watch child size
dummies flail violently in car booster
seats during a side impact crash test
in each case even here in this graco
video where the dummy's head escapes the
seat
and strikes the side the booster seats
all passed
because there are no federal standards
those tests
are shoddy and meaningless it was just
simply appalling
representatives raja christian morty and
katie porter launched a house oversight
committee investigation
involving seven brands of car booster
seats keep your kid in the harnessed car
seat following our cbs news propublica
reports in february
i have to credit you folks with really
shining a light on this issue
their findings obtained by cbs news
conclude booster seat makers
endangered the lives of millions of
american children and misled consumers
about the safety of booster seats
by failing to conduct appropriate side
impact testing
deceiving consumers with false and
misleading statements about their side
impact testing protocols
and unsafely recommending the children
under 40 pounds and as light as 30
pounds can use booster seats
the report also calls for the federal
trade commission and state attorneys
general to launch consumer protection
investigations
parents are relying on companies
to sell safe products and they're
relying on the federal government to
regulate
those products and unfortunately neither
of those two things happened
and that is disgraceful when the
manufacturer's guidance
is in fact a bunch of falsehoods and
lies
kids lives are being put at risk dr ben
hoffman is a lead author of car seat
recommendations for the american academy
of pediatrics there's not a scenario in
which
i would ever want to see a child under
40 pounds in a booster seat it's just
not necessary
we asked hoffman to review the test
videos obtained during the house
investigation
would you have given any of the booster
seats in those videos
a passing grade i can't imagine that i
would give those a passing grade
the videos where the impact was on the
far side
those were especially terrifying because
there was so much movement
of the head and neck of the dummy
outside of the shell of the booster seat
since at least 2002 the american academy
of pediatrics has recommended kids be at
least 40 pounds before transitioning to
a booster seat
canada has required it since 1987 but
u.s regulations
still allow for kids weighing as little
as 30 pounds to be in a booster do it
again
jillian brown was a 37 pound
five-year-old when the car she was
riding in
was hit from the side on the way to
school first thing i did was look back
to
see to check on the girls brown was
strapped into her even flow big kids
booster seat
the crash left her internally
decapitated paralyzing her from the neck
down
now nine years old she's kept alive by a
ventilator i would never have bought
that if i known
i would have left him in the
front-facing five-point harness for
years you know you read it and you
believe it evenflo says her booster seat
performed as designed
and jillian's injuries were primarily
due to the severity of the crash
and or driver error adding the seat
meets or exceeds federal standards
and passed the company's internal crash
tests the company settled a lawsuit with
the brown family
this summer but four years before the
crash that left
jillian paralyzed internal emails from
2012 show evenflo decided to spend 30
thousand dollars in additional labeling
costs
to market boosters to kids 30 pounds and
up in the u.s
instead of adopting the 40-pound
standard required in canada
for the same seats one executive writing
i have looked at 40 pounds for the u.s
numerous times and will not approve this
house investigators found several makers
have adopted a 40-pound minimum
evenflo and graco as recently as earlier
this year
but baby trend and kids embrace continue
to market their booster seats for
children as little as
30 pounds chico's website now has a 40
pound minimum
but we were able to buy this booster
tuesday that says
30 pounds and up as a parent
i am begging people to please not put
children
under 40 pounds in a booster seat
what we've seen from this investigation
is terrifying
and heartbreaking the companies all
declined to go on camera so did their
trade association which says in a
statement
a correctly used car seat is a child's
best defense
in a car crash reducing the risk of
injury by 45 percent compared with
vehicles seat belts alone
adding the industry supports stringent
federal standards now the report is also
critical of the national highway traffic
safety administration that would set
those standards
because despite being directed by
congress 20 years ago to create a side
impact crash test standard for car seats
the agency hasn't done it nitsa says the
process is quote highly complex
and those standards are coming soon so
parents what do you do
experts say that for kids in that 30
pound range they're safe as staying in a
car seat like this that has the five
point harness
until they grow out of it that's going
to be at least 40 pounds some go up to
65 pounds in fact if you look on the
side here this one even says
40 to 100 pounds to the booster and at
least four years old
then make the transition to a booster
seat now the oversight committee wants
to hear from parents we have more on
that as well as more from the car seat
companies
at cbsnews.com gail chris i am so
so happy that you're still on top of
this story you think as a parent
you put your child in a booster seat
they're okay clearly that is not always
the case depending on their weight such
important information and we'll put it
on our website
for people that couldn't that couldn't
take it all in in that one setting
very important information you just gave
us again this morning thank you chris
van cleef